welcome to this tutorial I'm too much
wave infarct a developer and instructor
from Sweden I created this tutorial for
free code camp and free code camp is
great
I also want to tell you that I have my
own YouTube channel baiban fault but for
now let's get started with this alright
this is the quiz that we're building in
this tutorial so we can start and we get
some questions here and we have 4
different choices to choose from so if
we press here you can see that it showed
me that I answered incorrectly and it
also showed me the correct answer and
then we can move on through the
questions here and this is all built
with react and type Swift so that's what
I'm going to show you in this tutorial
this is the finished application alright
so let's get started we're going to
bootstrap
application with create direct app and
we're going to set it to use typescript
so if we check the site here create -
react - app dev we can see that they
have they have an option for adding
typescript so we can use MPX create
react app and the name of the
application - - template and typescript
and this will install everything with
the typescript support for us so we can
do that so let's go inside of our
console here it and then we type in MPX
create - the react - app and then our
application is going to be named the
react - quiz in this case we type in - -
template and type script and we wait for
it so this will install everything with
types of support for us so we just have
to wait and it will be boot cut for us
okay that went smooth let's see what
we've got we have a react with folders
we can navigate inside of that one CD
react - quiz and then I open up the code
editor we're going to clean up or
product a little bit as you can see if
we look in the folder here we have some
files here and inside SRC folder we can
actually remove some stuff that we're
not going to need set up tests
serviceworker
the logo the index dot CSS the app dot
test dot t-- sx and the app dot CSS
remove those files like that and then
we're going to do some refactoring here
in the index dot TX file we can remove
this one where we ins where we import
the CSS file you can remove this one to
import a serviceworker and also remove
it down below here and this should be it
save the file and then in the apt of tsx
file we remove the CSS import and the
logo and for now we're just gonna say
quiz inside of here and do some more
formatting and save it then we're gonna
use star components to stall this one
I'm going to start it at the end of the
tutorial so we're just going to build
the functionality first but we can
install the dependence
for the star components and we can
install it by typing NPM I style it -
components and as this is in typescript
we're going to do this application we
also have to install the types for this
one and we can grab those ones from at
types forward slash style
- components like that
so we first installed the style
components library itself and then we
install the types for the style
components and we do it in one go so
press ENTER alright then we can just
start this up to see that it works
NPM start and we can go to localhost
port 3000 and you can see that it says
quits here and that's great we know that
it's working so localhost colon 3000
that's the dev server that this one
creates for us and you can see you can
also just click here and it will open up
in your browser hopefully all right so
that's the dependencies we only need to
install style components for this one as
a dependency but we have to do some more
stuff here first we're gonna have this
nice little summer background image and
I grabbed that one from unsplash.com
and I found this image down below here
it's not to add none that has
photographed this image so that's the
one I'm using so we can just download
this one or if you want to use another
image you can use that also so if we
check out this image it should be in the
download folder and you can see I
actually have two of them here because
I've already downloaded it before so
let's go inside the code editor again
and inside the SRC folder we're going to
create another folder that we call
images may be overkill for this one as
we only have one image but I like to
have a good structure on things so
images and then we grab this image and
drag it inside of there and I can
actually rename it also because it has
this strange long name we keep the name
of the guy der has taken the photo all
right so that's the images we also got
to need a couple of Google Forms so go
back to the web browser
I opened this one up for us I'm going to
use the form that's called catamaran I
don't know if I pronounced that
correctly yeah I'm gonna use the weight
of 700 so select this one I already
selected it here and I also gonna use a
form that's called fashion eight in line
these are the two fonts that I'm going
to use so I've selected that one also so
you can browse the fonts you can search
for them here and then you add them and
then we get this embed link here so copy
this link go back to our code editor and
we're going to navigate inside of the
public folder and we have the index dot
HTML and in this case we're going to
paste it in here so we import it in this
index dot HTML this is the file that is
run when the application is built so we
can import it here just like in a
regular HTML file save it and this will
make sure that we have those fonts all
right so that's the fonts I can close
this once and then we can just briefly
check out the API that we're going to
use for the questions so I found this
open trivia API as you can see we can
configure it we can select which
category we want I'm going to use the
ANA category we can select difficulty
I'm not going to implement to select
difficulty in the UI but I'm going to
implement it in the app itself so you
can change it in the code and we can
also change to have multiple choice or
true or false we're going to have
multiple choice and we're going to use
the default encoding and if we click
generate API URL it should generate the
URL for us up here so this is the URL
and this will give us a JSON response
with the questions and the answers as we
just get this object it will be really
is it a sheet if you want to do that
because you can always check the
questions and answers in the code
because if we want to make a serious
quiz game we probably have to create the
proxy API or already use an API that
won't show us the answers in the client
so we have to make a request to a server
and then it will get a response with
answers and stuff like that but in our
case for example if you have a react dev
tools you can just check the state and
you will see all the questions there and
the answers so it's a very simple
implementation of a quiz game and that
should be it for the setup let's move on
to create the logic for the application
and then last in the tutorial we're
going to create the UI the design for
the application ok make sure that you
have the application running by typing
in NPM start in the folder that we
created we'd create drag tap and it will
hopefully show Wis for you and it's also
a good idea to have the console open so
we can open that one up like that and
then move back to a code editor the
first thing I gonna do now is to create
a couple of new files and a folder
because we are going to create a
component for our questing card so
inside our SOC folder I create the new
folder that I call components and then
I'm going to create a file inside of
that one that I call question card not
TSX capital Q capital C question card
TSX and we can just scaffold this one
out for now so we import react from
react and then we create the Const
question card and an error function and
from now we can create a div that says
question court and we export default
question card do some more formatting
and save it so that is our question card
component we're going to come back to
this later and then inside of the SRC
folder we're going to create two more
files so first we have a file that we
call API dot TS capital letters on API
and then we have another file that I'm
going to call utils dot TS like that so
the API file is going to be used where I
create the logic for fetching data from
the API and the utils file is just going
to keep a small function that we're
going to use to randomize the answers to
the questions alright and we're going to
come back to those also and then later
we're going to create more files here
because when we create the Styles with a
start component I like to have the
Styles in a separate file so we're going
to create separate files for those also
but we do that when we've created all
the logic for this quiz game so let's
start off in the app dot tsx file this
is going to be the main file for our
application and if you want you can
change this
- an error function I like to have error
function but this is highly what we call
it highly subjective if you don't like
error functions you can use regular
functions so it's okay this is the main
component in our application so if we
start scheduling this one out we're
going to have one function that we fire
off when we start the quiz so cost start
trivia or start quiz start trivia I
think that is fun this one is going to
be async because we've got to make the
API call from this one so we can already
know marked it with async so we leave it
empty for now then we're going to have
one function that we're gonna trigger
when the user selects an answer so const
check answer equals this one is going to
take in the event like this and you can
see that it complains you know because
this is typescript they're telling us we
haven't specified the type for this one
so it's implicitly set to an e and we
should set a type for it so the event is
going to be a mouse event and we can
specify it even more so we specify two
HTML button element and we end it with a
angle bracket like that something like
that and of course we need to have a
colon here also and as we're in react I
guess we have to tell it react dot Mouse
event also like that
so ragtop Mouse event and then we
specify it even more by telling it it's
from an HTML button element so that's
how you type this event now we're gonna
have a function that will trigger when
the user click for the next question
so const next question equals and in
this one we don't actually need the
event so we just create an empty our
function like this this is all the
functions that we need for this trivia
and of course we're going to come back
to them in a second but first we're
going to scaffold out or JSX here in the
return statement
so we wrap it in a parenthesis first
like this and then we have the right
that's called at now we're gonna rename
these ones also later when we create the
star components but for now they will be
dibs with class names and first we're
gonna have an h1 tag with a header for
the quiz and we call it react quiz like
that then we're gonna have a button to
start the game so we create a button
with a class name pull start and we set
the onclick handler to the function that
we created start trivia like that and it
can just say and you can just say start
inside of it so that's the button then
we're gonna have a paragraph with a
class name of score and this is the one
that's gonna hold the score so for now
we're just setting score like this then
we're gonna have a paragraph with a
class name that is telling us loading
questions you can repost implement a
spinner or something if you want to do
that instead and then we're gonna have
our question card so we can import that
one up here I mark it with components
and import question cord from it's in
our components folder and then we have
the question corn like that so down
below here we create the question cord
like that and the last thing we're gonna
have is a button below everything of
this that is used to click to the next
question
so button class name equals next and for
this one we have an onclick handler next
question like that and we can just
well next question do some Auto
formatting so you can see that we're
using the next question and a start
trivia here this one here is going to be
sent in by props to the question cord
component so we can create the question
cord component now so let's go inside
the question card tsx file just as
before we create parentheses here we can
make an implicit return on this one so
we don't have to have a return statement
and as we were in typescript now we have
to type the props for this one so we
create a type to pull it props you can
call it whatever you want it doesn't
need to have the name props first we're
gonna give it the question and this one
is going to be a string the question is
always going to be a string then we're
going to give it all the answers and the
answers it is going to be an array of
strings so string array this is how you
type an array of strings then we're
going to give it a callback and for now
we can just set it to an E and we have
the user answer that's the answer that
the user is going to give us it's also
going to be a string we have the
question number it's going to be a
number we're still number like that then
we have total questions that one is also
going to be a number so these are the
props for this component but how do we
specify it to use these props first of
all we have to specify this one to be a
functional component so just after the
name here we have a column and from
react we have something that's called FC
so doped FC these are the types from
react itself so it will tell time trip
that this is a functional component and
if we want to specify props we do that
inside of angled brackets like this so
we tell it that we want to use these
props that we created up here and none
just as usual we turn the structure of
the props so we have the question we
have the answer you can see that we get
this nice auto completion
here where it tells us what we've got we
have the call back we have the user
answer we have the question number and
we have the total questions are going to
do some Auto formatting here because I
have this insanely large font because I
want you to be able to see what I'm
typing but it's hard to work with it
actually so these are the props that we
have now and now we can use them inside
or or component so this div is going to
be a rapid if I'm gonna create
parenthesis here again so we have the
rapid Eve we have the ending parenthesis
remove some stuff there so this is the
relative we're going to display the
current question that we're on so you
can do that in a P tag with a class name
of number and then we can type out
question :
and then from the props we're gonna grab
the question number like that and then
we do a forward slash and then we grab
the total questions like so because
we're in JSX now so when you want to
grab a JavaScript variable or create the
JavaScript expression we do that inside
of curly brackets alright so that is
going to indicate what question the user
is on and then we have the question
itself and in the response from the API
we're going to get some HTML in react we
have something that's called dangerously
set inner HTML that we can use when we
want to render out some HTML and it's
called like this because it is dangerous
to use because you never know what can
be injected there in our case we know
that it's safe so we can use it here so
we create a pit tag and we use
dangerously set inner HTML and we have
curly brackets then we have the new set
of curly brackets because it's an object
and we have underscore underscore HTML
and we're going to give it a question
now it shouldn't be the question number
it should be the question like that
alright then we're gonna have a wrapper
div for all the answers to the question
we're going to map through the answers
because we have all the answers in this
prop here
it should actually be called answers
with an S and not answer we can change
that one answers with an S so down below
here in the wrapping div we create curly
brackets and we have the answers dot map
so we met through them we have an answer
like that we create an inline arrow
function we can use implicit return here
also so we create parentheses and then
we have a wrapper for our button to
create another set of divs and inside of
the error created bottom it's gotta be
disabled depending on if the user has
made a choice if the user has answered
something so we set to disabled equals
user answer this one is going to be a
boolean so it will be disabled if this
one is user I'll say yeah I set it to a
string you can see that typescript
complains you know because I said it's
the string it will complain we will make
sure that this will get a true or false
value later so we have to change this
one now so it should be a boolean
instead you can see that it won't
complain anymore so this is one of the
great strengths with tight script it
will tell you when your code if you do
something wrong and you can correct it
before the bug even happens all right
then we have a long kick Handler on this
one and this is going to call the
callback like so we close it I'm gonna
have some text for the button also and
this one is also going to get the text
in HTML format so we create a span and
dangerously set inner HTML equals curly
brackets and we have the object with
another set of curly brackets underscore
underscore HTML and we give it the
answer in this case and then we self
close to spam do some Auto formatting
see that everything works I think it is
working yep save the file but now you
can see inside of the app dot tsx file
if we go back to that file so you can
see that it complains now because it
wants to props and we're going to give
it to props also but first I'm going to
create the states that
we're gonna use for this application and
we're gonna have six of them actually
because I'm gonna spit them up that's
great with hooks now you don't need to
have one big state we can have a few of
them instead so up here first we import
use state like that and just down below
here in the component at the beginning
we're gonna create our state's first
we're gonna have a loading state so
const loading and set loading like that
and we use stale we set it to false as a
default then we're gonna have the
questions like that and set questions
and we use state and we give it an empty
array for now we're also going to
specify this later give it a type but we
can't do that yet because i'm going to
create that type when we create a
function for the api then we have a
state with a number and set number and
this is going to be the number that the
user is currently on the question number
so use state we're gonna start at 0 then
we're gonna have a state for the user
answers and set user answers like that
and use stale and we give it an empty
array as initial value and then we're
gonna have the score and set score and
you still and this one is 0 as initial
value and then i also gonna have one
it's called game over and set game over
so that we can keep track on when the
game is finished so you stayed and we
set it to true initially okay so let's
give this question card its props first
we have the question number and this one
we're going to get from number but we're
going to add one because the number is
going to be used for the array
and the race starts at zero and we don't
want to start our questions with a zero
so we add one to this one because that
will make the first question to have the
number one okay then we have the total
questions and for this one we're going
to create a Const up here
Const and we have capital letter total
underscore questions equals ten and this
one is because it will be easy to just
change this for us if we want to modify
the total questions so total questions
is going to be the total underscore
questions like that then we're going to
have the question itself and we're gonna
grab this question from our question
state and we have the question state
here it's gonna be an array of questions
so if we want to give it a current
question we can do that with questions
and then we grab from number and then we
give it the question itself you can see
it complains now because so now
typescript doesn't know that it exists
with complaints here to us then we're
going to give it two answers and we have
our answers also in the questions number
and in a property that's called answers
like that and then we're going to give
it the actual answer from the user so
use your answer equals and then we check
if we have some user answers we create a
toner operator and if we have some
answers in the user answer state use
your answers we can grab the correct
answer by specifying the number
otherwise we just give it undefined like
that and you can see here yeah it should
say use your answers and this one will
complain out cause I realized that if we
go back to the question cord you can see
that tell this one that it's a boolean
it's actually not so we set it to Annie
for now go back to our app dot TSX file
and you can see that it won't
play now and the last one we're gonna
give it is the callback and it's going
to be the shaky answer like that
and now you can see that it won't
complain here because we're giving it
all the props it will just complain here
because it doesn't know that these
properties exist but we'll fix this soon
so I think we have everything set up now
actually and we can move over to the API
dot TS file and create the function that
will grab the data from the API so we
export Const fetch with questions like
that and this one is going to be async
and we're gonna have a couple of
parameters here because we want to be
able to specify how many questions that
we want to grab so we can create a
parameter amount it's going to be a
number and then we have another one that
we call difficulty and this is going to
be easy medium or hard because we can
grab these from the API so we should be
able to set it here how do we specify
this because it can only be easy medium
or hard and in typescript we have
something that's called an enum so
export enum we call it difficulty like
this and we can specify the constants
inside of here we have one that's called
EC and it's going to equal EC then we
have the medium one and it's gonna of
course equal medium make sure you have a
coma after these ones also and then we
have hard and it's going to equal hard
and I actually want to have a capital D
on difficulty so we can specify this
parameter as the enum difficulty alright
and this will make sure that we only can
use these values and it won't accept
anything else that way we won't make a
mistake of typing something like this
for example because then the end point
won't work so that's the parameters for
this one
then we want to specify the return type
it's going to be a promise of yeah I can
actually remove this one for now because
we're going to console.log out what we
get from the API first and then we can
see what type we're going to specify
this one so inside here we create a
Const with the endpoint I create a
template literal with backticks
so HTTP colon forward slash forward
slash open TD be calm for a slash API
dot PHP question mark amount and then we
have an equal sign and then we can grab
this variable here amount so we create
the dollar sign curly brackets and give
it the amount and this one around typing
in now is of course from the API so we
could of course just also copied it then
we have an ampersand and we're gonna
give it the next variable here so
difficulty equals and then where the
dollar saw in curly brackets and we give
it the difficulty argument and the last
one we have another ampersand and we set
the type equals to multiple so as you
can see can configure this as you want
in this case I'm just making sure that
we can change the amount and the
difficulty but you could change the type
and stuff like that and really customize
it how you want it to be we end it with
a semicolon alright so that's the end
point then in a cone star called data
I'm gonna wait because we are going to
hit that endpoint now so I await and
then I have a parenthesis I await again
I get a lot of questions on why I'm
using double awaits and that's because
first we await the fetch itself and then
we're going to wait when we convert it
to JSON so wait fetch parentheses we
give it the endpoint like that and then
here we have dot JSON and we call that
one so this will await the fetch itself
and then it will await when we convert
it to JSON and for now we're just going
to console log out the data
like so we're going to come back to this
one go back to the app dot TSX file and
I'm actually gonna comment out this one
for now so we don't have an error and up
here we can import that function that
we've created so import fetch quiz
questions from dot forward slash and we
have it in the API dot TS file like so
and what I want to do now is to try this
function out to see what we've got
so we have this function here fetch quiz
questions really hard to say for me and
we can call it here console.log fetch
with questions like that and we need to
give it two parameters now you consider
it complaints expected two arguments but
got zero so this is also great with
typescript it's telling us all the time
if we're doing something wrong so first
we're gonna give it the total questions
and then we need to give it easy medium
or hard and if you remember in the API
dot TS I'll we created this enum here
that I also also export so that means
that we can import this one in the app
dot TSX file so I'm going to mark this
one with types and I import difficulty
from dot forward slash API like so and
that means that we can use it here so in
our console log as the second argument
from difficulty we're going to grab the
easy one save it go back to our browser
you can see that we have everything here
now and here is the response you can see
that we have a response code of zero and
we have the result so this is what we
care about here
the 10 questions here and now we can see
the structure of the object the question
object here by looking at this one here
we can actually create the typed for
this one so we have a category the
correct answer and difficulty these are
all strings then we have the incorrect
answers in an array and then we have the
question and the type so let's move back
to the code and inside of the API dog TS
file I'm going to specify the type for
each question so type I'm going to
export this one also export type
question equals it's always good to
export stuff like this because you never
know when you need it in your
application so first if we go back to
the browser you can see that very
category correct answer difficult to
incorrect answer question and type so
now it's just a matter of specifying
this here category this one is going to
be screen we have the correct underscore
answer this one is also gonna be a
string we have the difficulty it's a
string we have the incorrect underscore
answer and this one is going to be an
array of strings so screen and an array
we have the question itself it's going
to be a string and then we have the type
it's also going to be string but one
thing I want to do here also because I
want to modify the stay that I get back
here because in this case we have the
correct answer in a separate property
and we have the incorrect answers in a
separate array I want to have them in
the same array because what I want to do
later is that I want to map through this
array and create the answers in the UI
in the JSX
so it's easier to have them in one array
so we can have both the correct answer
and incorrect answers in one array
instead so i'm going to add a property
in the object that we returned here from
the api and we also have to specify that
with type swift of course and how do you
do that well I'm going to create another
type IX port type and I'm going to call
it question state
so first I grab the question that I
created here but I want to add something
to this one so I create an ampersand and
then I have an object I'm going to
create a new property that's called
answers and this one is going to be an
array of strings so like that you saw
more formatting so this will use the
types from the question but add this
property to it and it will create this
question state type instead so we all
good to go now we can return the correct
data here in the fetch quiz questions
there is actually misspelled here
questions it should sell and I need to
change it in the app also like so and
also here yeah something like that go
back to the API dot t-- s file alright
so we know that we get our data then we
have to return some things so our return
and from the data dot results I'm going
to map through all of them and add this
property that I talked about it's a map
we have a question and now we can
specify it as a question from our type
question like that we make an implicit
return we have a pair of curly brackets
because we return on object and then we
spread the question we want to use all
the properties that we get from the
question and you can do that with es6
syntax that's called spread so that's
what we're doing here and then we add
the new property of answer and there's
actually one more thing I want to do
because I want to shuffle the array here
otherwise the correct answer will always
be on the same place and that's why I
created this utils dot TS file so move
inside of that one and we create another
small function here export Const shuffle
array and this one takes in the array
and it can be of any type in the array
for this one we have an error function
so this array that we give this function
I'm gonna create a new array by
spreading it inside of a new one this is
also a year six intact spreading
inside of here creating a new array and
then I use sort give it an inline error
function and use math dot random minus
0.5 do some water formatting and this is
kind of a quick fix for creating a
randomizer function it's not completely
accurate but in our case it will do so
this yeah this have to do for now this
is not a tutorial about creating random
functions so this will do the trick for
us this will do the job so save it and
go back inside the API dot TS file and
up here at the top we can import this
one so import shuffle array from dot
forward slash and utils like so so go
back below here where we create the
object and inside the answer property
I'm gonna call the shuffle array and
give it the array that I want to shuffle
so yet again I use es6 syntax I create
an array I spread from the question dot
the incorrect answer you can see here
typescript gives us all the properties
that's available for us
so the question dot incorrect answer and
then from the question dot correct
answers correct answer so we spread all
the incorrect answers and the correct
answer and then we shuffle it with this
function here do some more formatting
and it will look something like this
yeah and before we do anything this one
should be in correct answers right so I
keep forgetting these SS I don't know
why but I keep forgetting them make sure
that it says incorrect answers with an S
and also change the type to that one
save it and this one goes also here this
property here should be called answers
with an S yeah because it
answers here also so keep forgetting
those SS add them to these ones
otherwise it won't work alright save it
go back to the browser reload it and you
can see now we have a promise here but
we can see that it's resold and if we
look at the question here you can see
that we have the new property with
answers here so you can see that the
correct answer for this one is bull we
have that one inside of here and the
incorrect answers is bad horse and snake
and we also have these ones so this is
exactly what we want now we have an easy
way to map through all the answers when
we do that all right so let's get back
inside of the code this is the API or TS
file it's finished now and also the
utils of TS is finished so back inside
the app dot TSX file so in the types
we're also going to use the question
state the question state that's the one
that we created we import that one also
here and now we can set this one is
going to be an array of the type
question state so you can specify that
one here inside of the angled brackets
question state and an array like that my
script will know because we're sending
this to an empty array it can't really
know what this is going to be but but
specifying like this we tell type if
that this is going to be an array of
question state so we have to create this
type for the answer object also just
below here we create a new type we don't
have to export this one because we're
not using it in another component answer
object equals and the answer is going to
have a property with a question it's
going to be a string we're going to have
the answer and this is a string we're
going to have a correct that's the
boolean like so and then we have the
correct answer and it's a string so the
correct will tell if the user answered
correctly and the correct answer will
have the correct answer and then we have
the user answer here and we will start
the question and this is good to have a
complete object like this because if we
for example want to extend or game and
show all the questions in the end when
the quiz is finished we have them nicely
in this array
that's called use your answers we're not
really going to do that now but I
created it this way so you can kind of
extend from here if you want to do that
now we can specify this user answers so
we create angle brackets and answer
objects and an array so then we have all
our types for the state's save it and
just make sure that it still works it
does so that's great so we're going to
implement the stork trivia function now
so that we can start a game so inside of
that function we have to do some stuff
here first when we click the start
button we're going to trigger the API
fetch and that means that we're loading
something so we're going to set the
loading to true that's the first thing
that we do and we're also going to set
the game over to false because when we
start a new game it's not game over so
when we done that when we set the
loading and the game over we can hit the
end point so we create a Const new
questions then we're going to wait and
we call the fetch quiz questions and
we're going to give it to two arguments
that it needs it needs the total
questions and just as before we give it
a difficulty dot EC as the second
argument all right so that will grab the
new questions and put it in this comes
here so when we awaited this one and we
have all the questions we can set the
questions with the new questions like
that
and hopefully we have all the questions
in this state and in this tutorial I'm
not doing an error handling so you could
of course use a try or catch lock and if
you want to catch the error or something
like that
this video is already getting long so I
won't go into that here but you should
of course always do some arrow handling
if you have an error all right then we
also got to set the score to zero
because we're starting from scratch now
so it should be reset and we set the
user answers to an empty array so we can
do
setting everything here it's a set
number we also said in that one to zero
and then when we've done all of this we
hopefully have or questions in or stayed
and everything is working then we can
set the loading the force because we're
not loading anymore and this is it for
the start preview function so save it go
back here and click start you can see
that we get the promise here but that's
because we're console logging it out
here we can remove this one here and
actually just console.log out the
questions instead so go back to the
browser press start you can see that we
have all the questions inside of here
and you shouldn't worry because you may
wonder why whoa if we rerun this a lot
of stuff here but that's fine there's no
performance issue here that's because we
have a lot of these states that will
trigger a render but it will only render
stuff that is new for each render so you
shouldn't worry too much about that
especially not in a small app like this
all right so we know that we have our
questions in the state that's fine it's
working really nice but for now also you
can see that just as loading questions
we want to display the questions and the
answers here also so we can modify our
JSX here so first this button here to
start the game is only going to be
displayed if the game is over or if the
user has answered the last question so
we create curly brackets we check if
game over or we have double pipe user
answers dot length equals total
questions then we know that we're on the
last question and then we're going to
display this button it can get a little
bit messy here now so we have
parentheses around that one otherwise we
return null we have the ending curly
bracket there like so I think and you
could also do a regular short-circuit
without this Turner operator if you want
to do
but I think it's ready to return at
least null and as you can see now it
displays the button but not now when we
press it so that's working okay that's
the start button and then we want to
show the score we only want to show the
score if we're not in a game over mode
for this one so curly brackets not game
over we have another Turner operator and
otherwise we show null and we have the
end curly bracket like so and the
loading questions is only going to be
shown when we load something so curly
braket loading like so and no yeah it
may be better to just have a short
circuit I can do it like this for this
one so if it's loading is going to show
this one save it and we can see what
we've got so we have start the next
question we start you can see that the
loading was showing and we show the
score so this is working also go back to
the code now we're going to bring back
the question card and the question card
is only going to be shown if we're not
loading and if we're not in game over so
we created curly brackets not loading
and not game over yeah I do a short
circuit here a little bit messy here
again something like that do some more
formatting so if we're not loading and
if it's not game over we're gonna show
the question card save it go back to the
browser start you can see that where the
question and the answers here that's
sweet now we have the next question
button also but we haven't implemented
those functions yet all right that's the
question card and then we have the next
button and this one is only going to be
shown if we're not in a game over and
we're not loading
the user answers dot length equals
number plus one and by doing this we
just want to show the next question when
the user actually has put in an answer
so that's why we shake it here if the
user answers dot length equals number
plus one so we don't show it if the user
haven't given us an answer yet and the
last thing we want to check if we're not
on the last question so number not
equals total questions but we have to
modify this one also because we have to
set it to minus one and then I have a
question mark parenthesis this is really
messy here now I'm gonna move off the
bottom inside of there and down below
here :
and now yeah it should just be two equal
signs there of course and do some order
formatting and I think that this will
work go back to the browser
yeah so now it's not showing because we
have to give an answer first before we
showing that one
yeah and it's telling me that it should
have a key prop here we're going to fix
that one also and that one is in the
question chord because here where we map
through this ones we should have a key
and we can give it the answer as a key
and this will make this arrow go away or
this morning all right so this is
working now go back to the app dot tsx
we're going to implement the other
functions now and then the game will
work and then we can move on to create
the star for this one so inside the
check answer first we're only going to
run this function if we're not in a game
over so if not game over then we get the
user's answer Const answer equals and
get that from the e-dot current target
dot value because this is when we press
that button here so you can see that we
calling this callback on click and
that's why we also have to set this
value on here it's a value we give it
the answer like this otherwise we won't
be able to read the values it's very
important to set the value also on the
button here on the question cord in the
question core component like that go
back to the app dot TSX
so from e dot current target dot value
we'd get that value and that's going to
be the answer then we're going to check
answer against the correct value or the
correct answer so cons correct equals
from questions we have the current
number that's the question that we're on
we have the property that's called
correct underscore answer and we check
if that one equals the answer then we
know if if it's correct or not so this
will give us true or false add score if
answer is correct
so if correct set score and we have the
previous score and we add it by one like
so all right so that's if it's correct
then we add to the score and then we're
going to save the answer in the array of
answers here and we have this answer
object we're going to give it a question
answer correct and correct answer so
that's what we're selling here so save
answer in the array for user answers
something like that comes answer object
equals and we create an object question
the questions number we grabbed the
question and then we have the answer
then we have the correct and this is
also es6 syntax if this one is the same
this is exactly the same as typing out
answer when these two are the same we
just need to type it out once like this
and then we have the correct answer
and from questions and the number we
have the property that's called correct
answer it's a water formatting and this
will make sure that it raises object
with the data about the answer and then
we need to put it in the answer array so
set user answers we have the previous
state and we create a new array spread
out the previous and we give it to
answer object or a format it and save it
and this should be it for answers go
back to the browser see that it works
reloaded start yeah you can see the next
question is showing up also but is not
working now because we haven't
implemented this function but it seems
to be working so we just have to
implement that function also and then we
have a fully working game but it will
look like crap because we haven't styled
it yet so we have the next question
function here move on to the next
question if not the last question so we
have to check if we are on the last
question the cost next question equals
number plus one because the question
recurrently on is the number and then we
add to one and then we can check if this
is the last question or not so if next
question equals total questions we know
that that one is the last question
because total questions is always going
to be one number ahead of the number
because we're using this for the array
that starts at index zero and this one
doesn't do that so we have to add one so
when we check the next question with the
total questions that will give us the
answer if we're on the last question and
if we're on the last question we set
game over to true like so else we're not
on the last questions we can set the
number to the next question like so or a
format it and save it and go back to the
browser reload it just to be sure and
start select an answer which of the
following was not one of the Magnificent
Seven oh I really don't know actually
next question and you can see it will
move through the questions we can't see
the correct answer now because we
haven't styled it but it seems to be
working let's see what it does when it's
on the last question you can see it
displays the start button when we're on
the last question and it's not
displaying the next question so we can
restore the game and it's working quite
nicely I think but as I told you we
can't really see if we put him the
correct answer because we do all that
stuff with a styling and that's what
we're going to do next we're going to
use star components to style this quiz
all right before we move on with the
styling for this one I'm gonna fix these
types because I forgot that we had these
any types here and if we can fix it we
should do that so we can type this
correctly and we're going to change this
call back and the user answer so for the
cool back we already have the types for
that one in the app dot tsx file if we
go down here to that function this check
answer function we are already typing
this one here so you can just copy this
one like that copy that one go back to
the question card or tsx file and
replace the anny with this one instead
and we're going to return void for this
one we're not returning anything so we
can specify it as void so that's the
callback and the user answer we actually
created the type of this one also in the
apt of tsx file
we have this answer object I think I
said that we didn't need to export this
one but we have to export it because we
can use it in the question card now to
specify that type so add an export to
that one and then we can import it in
the question card or tsx so add an
export save the file and then go back to
the question card or tsx and up here we
can mark it with types so import answer
object and we import it from dot forward
slash app something like that so we have
the type here now for the user answer so
instead of an e we can use answer object
but it can also be undefined so you
create a pipe and specify it as
undefined
like that save the file and there's also
one more thing we have to do now because
down here this one disabled it wants a
boolean and this one is not a boolean
now so if we want to convert this one to
a boolean value we can use double Banks
double exclamation marks or we can
specify it like this with a ternary
operator if we have the user answer we
set it to true otherwise we set it to
false so it's up to you you can use
whatever you want but just make sure
that you give this one a boolean value
otherwise it won't work so this is it
this is all the types now we don't have
any any type now except in this utils
function because this one can take an
array with an e value so make sure to
save the files and I'm also gonna check
so that it works go back to the browser
reload it and it still works and that's
great so that's the types let's move on
with a styling ok we're going to give
this quiz some styling but first we have
to also make sure that we display the
score I forgot that one so we have this
state with scores move down here to the
JSX in the app dot TSX component just
somewhere here yeah here well we set the
score we're actually not showing
anything there now we're gonna add that
one here so we have curly brackets and
we show the score like that this will
make sure that we show the score to the
user and you should be able to see yeah
yeah I got a score one there yes you can
see it it's displaying nice alright so
we're gonna create a new file now we're
going to create some styling for the app
dot TSX file first so inside the source
folder the SRC folder create a new file
F dot stars dot t-- s and we're going to
import some stuff from star components
so import styled coma and then with the
structure out create global style like
that from dot style components so style
is the regular thing that you import and
we're also importing create global style
I think it is self explaining we're
going to create some global styling with
that one
that's the first thing that we're going
to do but first we also want to import
our background image be the image you
can call it whatever you want from dot
forward slash images forward slash and
then we have that I really don't know
why it can't find it yeah and this one
is complaining because I removed the
test file before I think that shouldn't
matter but this is strange I think we
just created TS ignore for this one from
now something like that I think it will
work we'll see if it worked
later so export comes global style you
can call it whatever you want you don't
need to call it global style but we call
the great global style with double
backticks and we can create a global
styling
we set the HTML I'm gonna set the height
to 100% on that one and just as usual
when I style stuff like this there are
some room for optimization I think I
just did it Styles really quickly so
there probably will be more effective
ways of doing stuff here but I mean a
summer vacation mode now so this will
probably be one of the last videos
before I take a well-deserved vacation
so that's why I actually didn't think I
was going to do this before the summer
but then I felt yeah why not
so that's why I created this one all
right so we have the body we set the
background - image to the URL and then
we can grab this URL with dollar sign
curly brackets biggie image like that
and then we set the background size to
cover i set the margin to zero the
padding is gonna be zero and 20 pixels i
set to display the flicks and justify
content to sender so that's the body and
then i have an asterisk I'm gonna set
the box sizing what sizing the border
box and I'm also gonna set the font on
every element on this one so fun family
catamaran and Sam's reef as a fullback
font all right so that's the global
styling I'm actually going to import
that one in the app component now to see
if this background image works so go
back to the app dot TSX file and up here
I mark it with styles I import global
style from code /f taught styles and
then when you create a global style with
star components we get the regular come
volunteer so we can use that one down in
the JSX you can put it somewhere here at
the top so I create a fragment because
the SX can only return one element I
close it here and then we can use the
Globalstar component like this do some
Auto formatting and save it go back to
the application
yeah and the image worked I don't really
know why it complained there so if it
complains just add a little comment here
that I created the comment this one out
I don't really know because it worked in
my application when I created this
example so don't really know why but
that's the global styling and then we
can do some styling in the app itself so
export Const I'm gonna create a
component that I call wrapper style dot
div double backticks
it's going to be displayed as flex flex
direction
it's gonna be column and align items is
going to be centered like so then I want
to style the P tag in this wrapper
so I created a forward error and the p2
just style the P tag in this app wrapper
I don't want it to be styled on all the
P tags so I set the color to white so
that's the P tag then I'm going to have
a class that I call score and that's of
course the score table
I set the color there also the white we
could of course specify some CSS
variables for the colors if we want to
do that that's one way you can optimize
this CSS I set the font size to 2 or M
the Morgan is gonna be 0 on this one all
right so that's the score class then we
have the h1 tag and this is going to be
this one up here that's going to be the
actual logo that I'm styling with CSS
all right so the font family is gonna be
fascinate inline not impact in line like
that then I set the background image and
this one is going to be the linear
gradient it's a linear - gradient and
inside it's going to be 180 degrees
unrelated egg I said the first
evaluative white and the second one is
going to be 8 7 F 1 FF and to be able to
show this linear gradient in the font we
also have to set the background size
100% and the background - kit is going
to be text then we can all
all the WebKit stuff here for this one
so WebKit - background Kip it's gonna be
text WebKit - text - Phil color is going
to be transparent and we have the moss
door - background clip it's gonna be
text and we have the most text - fill -
color it's gonna be transparent double -
maybe all right now we're gonna have
some drop shadow on this one so we set
the filter to drop - shadow and two
pixels two pixels and the color is going
to be 0 0 8 5 a3 the font size is gonna
be 70 pixels text the line it's going to
be Center and if Morgan is gonna be 20
pixels on this one okay we're not really
finished yet but we can import these
Styles inside of here in the app dot TSX
file just to see that this one works
so we import the wrapper and below here
we have to change your JSX because now
instead of this deep with class name app
we're gonna use the wrapper component
and make sure to also close it down
below here save it go back to the
browser and you can see that it's not
quite working here and I don't know why
I think it's those I thought stars I
think maybe this one's should be just
one and I also want to set the font
weight 400 on this one save it go back
yeah and now it's working so there's a
little bit of
trouble doing stuff like this as you can
see there's a little bit of special
syntax here to get it to work if you
don't like to do it this way you can
save that logo as an SVG file instead
and that will also work just fine all
right
then we have a couple of more classes
here so we have the start and the dot
next class I'm going to set the cursor
to a pointer I'm gonna set the
background on these ones as a linear
gradient her own 80 degrees on that one
also I set it to white and then the
second color is going to be ffcc not in
one so that's the start on the next
button
we set the border to two pixels solid
and the color is going to be d three
eight five five eight like so I'm gonna
have a book shadow zero pixels five
pixels ten pixels and then I set there
RG be a 0 0 0 and 0.5 no 0.25 on the
book shadow I set the border radius to
10 pixels and the height is gonna be 40
pixels Morgan is gonna be 20 pixels 0
and the padding is gonna be 0 40 pixels
like so and then I want to do some
special styling on the start button so
max - width is 200 pixels order format
it and save it go back to the browser
and this should be it hopefully start
you can see that the next button is also
style here but we're not styling the
actual question card now so that's what
we're going to do next
right so inside a components folder we
have our question card to create a new
file question cord dots tiles the tears
and for this one we import style
Rome style components then we export
Const wrath per stylist deal you can see
also that in this tutorial I just
created a wrapper and then I have
regular classes you can of course create
a style component for each little thing
if you want to do that but sometimes I
think it's overkill so it's just enough
to have this wrapper and I create
classes in this case I'm also going to
have a bottom wrapper on this question
cards so I create two components for
this one but it's fully legit to just
have a wrapper and then you have your
classes inside if you don't want to
create a start components for every
little thing in your application all
right
we set a max width on this one to eleven
hundred pixels
I set the background to EB F e FF I set
the border dash radius to ten pixels
I set the border to two pixels solid and
the color is going to be 0 0 8 5 a3 the
pairing is gonna be 20 pixels and I have
a book shadow on this one also so book
shadow zero pixels 5 pixels 10 pixels
rgba 0 0 0 and 0.25 and it takes the
line it's gonna be centered right then I
start the P tag for this one we're gonna
set the font size to 1 RM like that so
that's the wrapper component then we
have the bottom wrapper so export comes
bottom wrapper equal style
give and this one is actually going to
take in some props and how do you do
that in star components well we can
create a type here for example type
bottom wrapper of props and it's going
to take in two props correct that's
going to be a boolean and you see
clicked that's also going to be a
boolean all right and to use these props
in the star components we create angle
brackets here and we specify the bottom
wrapper props and then we have double
backticks then we can go on just as
usual here and on this bottom wrapper
I'm going to set a transition I'm lazy
I'm just turning it to all zero point
three seconds and ease the hover is
gonna be I set the opacity to 0.8 when
we hover over the button and now we have
the burn on itself
Sabourin i set the cursor to a pointer
the use of select it's gonna be none I
don't want the user to be able to select
the text the font size it's gonna be 0.8
aureum the width is 100%
the height is 40 pixels the margin is 5
pixels and zero on this one then we're
going to set the background and this one
is going to be a nested ternary because
we want to change the background
depending on if we're showing the
correct answer or if the user put in the
wrong answer so we set the background
and in star components we can grab the
props by dollar sign curly brackets and
then I can the structure of them like
this so we have the correct prop and the
user clicked prop and then we have the
inline function here so first we're
going to check if correct if that one is
true
have at owner/operator then I set the
linear gradient to 90 degrees and the
color is going to be 5 6 f f/a 4 as the
first color and the second color is
going to be 5 9 bc 8 6 like so so that's
the first linear gradient so that is if
it's the correct answer then it's going
to show in green then we have the colon
and then we have a nested Turner
operator here so if not correct and the
user clicked so the user clicked is
going to tell us if the user clicked on
that specific button so we have a nested
ternary operator here so we have another
question mark and I can actually just
copy this this one here paste it in and
I can change these values here this one
is going to be FF 5 6 5 6 and this one
is going to be C 1 6 8 6 8 and we add in
the last one here so : we had the last
linear gradient this one is gonna be 5 6
c c FF + 6 e a FB for do some auto
formatting but I have some mistake here
yeah just because that question mark
shouldn't be there or a format it and
that's the background then we have some
few more properties to set here I'm
gonna set the border the three peaks are
solid white I'm gonna set the box shadow
one pixel
- pixel zero pixel rgba 0 0 0 and 0.1
all right almost finished here with a
styling border-radius is going to be 10
pixels on this one and the color is
going to be white and the last one is
the text shadow zero pixels one pixel
zero pixel rgba 0 0 0 and 0.25 and all
for merit so that's the styling now we
just need to implement it in the
component itself so optimize it if you
want to do that at least it works now
but it may not be the most optimized CSS
so go back to the question card dot TSX
file and up here at the top we first
gonna import our Styles import wrapper
and bottom wrapper from dot forward
slash question car Styles like that and
then we have to modify our DSX here a
little bit so first we have this rapid
if that of course is going to be the
wrapper make sure to end it with the
wrapper also then there's nothing here
to change this one is the bottom wrapper
so this one is going to change
it's going to be the bottom wrapper and
if you remember we're going to send in
two props to this one also because it's
complaining now you can see it wants two
props so the key is correct there that's
fine but we're going to add in the props
here so correct that's the prop we're
gonna check the user answer and here I'm
using something that's called optional
chaining in typescript so I create a
question mark dot and the correct answer
and I check it
if that one equals the answer we should
have triple equal sign so if I remove
this one we don't actually know if we
have a value here but if we use the
question mark this one will not throw an
error it will make this on the front if
you don't have an answer here so that's
why I'm using optional chaining then we
have the user clicked so user answer yet
again I use the optional chaining dot
answer equals answer or a format it so
if we don't have this one here it will
throw an error if we don't have a user
answer but by specifying like this it
won't throw an error and I think this
actually should be it so save it go back
to the application with tryout start and
yes we have our question here that's
what okay that was right you know that
one all right the next question so as
you can see I answered wrong but it's
given me the correct answer here so
everything seems to be working fine
yeah and that's the
question and then it gives us the start
button again so the quiz is working and
that's super sweet so this is how you
build a fairly simple little quiz game
with react and typescript there are room
for improvement but hopefully this gave
you some insight in how it is to build
an application with typescript and react
so if you like this kind of tutorials
make sure to subscribe and support me I
will put out these tutorials regularly
on my channel and hopefully I see you in
another one